let's talk about my main man chris pratt
yeah the [ __ ] legend i love this oh
gee i love this guy i actually do love
chris pratt he's great guardians of the
galaxy great jurassic world great
hilarious actor great fun like literally
hilarious funny actor [ __ ] body he is
a body he uh is not allowing hollywood
to just bully him into being one of
these [ __ ] hollywood clones yep like
the dude is religious and he's like i'm
gonna be religious yep and also
hollywood only makes you do that if
you're like into white religion
you know i mean like if you're like like
hollywood has never said denzel cut it
out with the religious stuff in all your
movies
every denzel movie book of eli is about
how the bible could save the world every
denzel movie he makes sure he puts it in
because it's important to him he
believes in it that's his life is that a
thing he does
i did not know that
and you'll know it'll be like a little
thing but or it'll be the driving force
of the holy man on fire was he always
reading the bible is that a thing
but like uh training
oh he had a cross i guess yeah jesus
piece bro yeah oh yeah that was fire but
like uh
but yeah i don't know but i'm just it is
interesting though like
like i i doubt that hollywood would make
you go hey listen i know there's some
[ __ ] up they would want me to parade
it out there yeah it'd be even better
because hindu is possible
yeah islam denounced christianity
yeah but
the it's so funny and they call him out
for things that his religion is against
that all the other religions are against
but they would never call them out for
right and they've never called out a
muslim actor
yep right for the fact that their
religion uh doesn't like gay cakes
yeah right yeah
he's referring to the gay cake story
that people would go to like um
muslim bakers and be like hey will you
make this cake and be like no well do
they even make cakes like do does like
islam have a lot of cakes is that like a
birthday cake country honey cake
oh honey honey cakes but do you make a
gift
but like for a wedding for a muslim
wedding would you have cake or would you
have some type of other dessert
i don't know i don't know if you have
cake
do they have a four-tiered like cake
i i don't know if it's four-tier i mean
how about how the muslims i know have
bean pies twin towers
they're big on pastries
[Laughter]
the [ __ ]
i thought the bean pie was like a korean
like a red bean paste no no that's a
black muslim thing yeah no but korean
pies koreans also have uh oh they do
they do desserts yeah i think japan or
the japanese do it as well yeah i love
those yeah so this is what they call the
traditional muslim wedding i'm not
allowed to read that
say it out
a nica ceremony anika
yeah but isn't the name of the outfit
that the women wear called uh nakeeb
nakeeb yeah okay so maybe that's nothing
so they're just dropping em bombs all
over the way they say it it's like a
real strong k so it's even more really
like i wouldn't say unless i'm around
indians so they know i'm not have you
heard that word before yeah oh really
yeah
uh-huh yeah i forgot until he said and
then i was like oh how do you guys say
it in hindu
shoddy
[Laughter]
no no no their version oh i won't do it
around y'all
no
be honest you won't do it right now
i would feel weird doing it around you
guys too because it'd make me sound
crazy oh that's crazy but it looks like
yeah they got a regular cake and they
call it that word bro there's a japanese
whiskey called nikka
whiskey oh yeah it's super popular yeah
and i was ordinated
i'm asking for high balls a high ball
isn't whiskey's watching over here with
a lime right and i'm out there in japan
and asked for high buzz they're like do
you have a choice of whiskey do i
but yeah i don't think we got 10 days
white white bakers shouldn't be allowed
to make this cake white bakers are not
allowed to make that yeah and if a black
people comes and says hey i need you to
make this this muslim cake i would say
can't do it what do you call black baker
what do you call a baker you racist
bro you guys are [ __ ] racist dude
crazy you guys are [ __ ] racist bro
stuff like why is that that is so
[ __ ] rare what black baker can't be
called a baker too i know
jesus wow why is that why why are you
yeah like you're rolling your [ __ ]
eyes like black people can't bake [ __ ]
yeah you blacked out what you wanted
you wanted
that's what it is okay just chill the
[ __ ] out
okay goodness gracious so chris pat
can't play mario because he's not
italian well they're now they're getting
upset mario all right go ahead okay
first of all we don't know if the mario
brothers were italian no they're not did
they ever sexually harass princess peach
i don't think so
italians we don't even know if we should
want to be saved why do you think she
was running she's happily married
she's happily married in a castle
holy [ __ ] if they grab princess peach's
ass without her consent said you're not
my boss anymore i can do this now yeah
why do you think they called her peach
her name was diane yeah
they were like oh there's a little peach
over here they're just sexually
harassing we don't know if it's sexual
but they're harassing this woman they're
harassing this woman yeah we have to
acknowledge it as harassment they're
plumbers like i don't know if i don't
know a ton of plumbers but i don't know
if they're the most uh socially
conscious created by two japanese guys
so oh so that's their idea of italians
what were they drinking huh that's what
they think italians are just a bunch of
[ __ ] plumbers sexually harassing
women who the [ __ ] do they think they
are wow
exceptional game developers that stood
the test of time okay did they do that
did they do the voice do they do the
italian accent the japanese guys it's
ami
mario yeah yeah that's pretty offensive
yeah dude and what if we just did their
voice what if we did the voice of
toadstool who was obviously japanese
i mean y'all thought he was too keeping
the [ __ ] right
those japanese
yeah yeah everybody was japanese in that
game except the people that weren't mike
racine had a funny joke he said amaro's
not being played by whatever and then uh
yoshi's not even being being played by a
jew why why is it yo she had them oh
[ __ ]
that was just that was browning out
right now
yeah you don't get it though yeah i'm
good okay oh jewish jokes go with it is
that okay okay
yeah i never saw yoshi as a jew because
like he's like helping
[Laughter]
you know
he's just helping the whole time he's
like hey mario how can i help you
he's a dino brother
democratic name
okay
um obviously italians are going to want
an italian but which italian do you want
to play mario [ __ ] de niro
who's the italian that gets to play
mario
yeah there's nobody left yeah yeah like
what young italian actor is going to
play sebastian sebastian sebastian would
kill it woody sebastian mckiller
scorsese
martin scorsese jumping up that's a
[ __ ] sebastian sebastian can do like
the when he has all the like the patches
on the body mm-hmm you know when they're
doing 2k yeah to get all the moves down
i don't want matteo lane to play mario
oh
[ __ ] nah luigi
sebastian's playing spike don't know who
that is
but he's actually in the movie yeah
jack black is playing bowser
i'm gonna be in this movie
i believe it i'm gonna be waluigi i
believe it yo i'm putting this out right
now i'm gonna be waluigi and the
internet's gonna go crazy yeah yeah
because the internet casted me
you